lors d'une cérémonie très codifié ils
sont là pour recevoir les condoléances
des présidents des deux chambres en
présence de la première ministre liste
des hauts fonds et notre chagrin no yoru
même si nous savons que votre père est
encore plus grand
[Musique]
elle a donné l'exemple d'une dévotion
des intéressés ce que je suis avec
l'aide de dieu et de vos conseils résolu
à suivre fidèlement des internautes ont
repéré ce geste de la main un brun
dédaigneux pour compte débarrasse un
encrier de la table la séquence cumule
plus de 25 millions de vu et lui vaut
d'être qualifié de roi désagréable avec
le petit personnel esclaves débarrasser
moi ce bureau en 2022 un juan ne peut
plus tout se permettre surtout s'il veut
être populaire alors stress des
nouvelles responsabilités ou mauvaises
habitudes d'éternelle assisté en tout
cas ça promet pour la suite je pense que
les habitants d'edimbourg sont à la
hauteur de l'événement et lui font les
adieux qu'elle mérite et je pense
qu'elle serait fière de son peuple hélas
ce produit quelque chose qui serait
inimaginable dans le reste du pays
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maintenir l'unité du royaume ça va être
ça le point le plus essentiel est
peut-être le plus délicat unités du
royaume avec l'irlande du nord avec les
cos est aussi unités du commonwealth il
n'est pas sûr que des pays qui se
réclamaient jusqu'à présent de la
couronne britannique vont continuer à le
faire avec charles nous verrons bien le
royaume uni est fondamentalement
anti-démocratique ont un droit qui n'est
pas élue une première ministre qui n'a
pas été élu
elle n'a même pas le droit de décider si
les causes doit être un pays indépendant
ça me garde toute cette démonstration
ridicule ce deuil on nous impose la
monarchie vit par l'image ça ils ont
compris ils sont la rolls royce des
monarchies parce que il maîtrise les
codes comme personne et on va vraiment
voir dans les jours qui viennent ce que
l'on pourrait qualifier de spectacle on
est en on va être en mode mondiovision
c'est une super production made in
england pour lui c'est déjà décrit comme
l'un des plus grands événements
diplomatiques du siècle avec une liste
d'invités sans précédent sont attendus
les chefs d'état français et américains
japonais turc néo zélandais des membres
de familles royales du monde entier bref
il y a tellement d'inviter qui il est
demandé aux chefs d'états de venir
accompagné seulement de leur conjoint je
vois que quand une gamine de 21 ans
parce qu'elle est à côté d'un type qui
veut pas s'arrêter moi ce qui m'émeut
j'ai cette malheureuse qu'est mort
j'approuve rohmer il a attendu à la
maison pour rien je ne suis pas d'accord
et rien ne me fera taire sur ce sujet
certainement pas de facture pour en
revenir à jean luc mélenchon s'il fait
des crises de nerfs c'est parce que vous
savez la mégalomanie ça existe est ce
que regrette jean-luc mélenchon sait que
ce n'est pas lui qui soit célébré 24
heures sur 24
et je ne suis pas sûr que les drapeaux
français soit en berne le jour de son
départ je suis féministe
et là ça suffit
ça sur
des murs vous êtes un juré va qu'on me
dise et qu'on me faire engueuler
d'accord et yann donc vous arrêtez de
m'engueuler gens vous engueuler paillade
mais si les papes afrique c'est affaire
de goût les médias mais non mais c'est
pas venir il a arrêté de m'engueuler
d'abord je vous engueuler pas malgré
l'exil bourdy quelque chose qui pourrait
être sinon rien j'ai choisi mon rôle ogg
et je suis pas venu ici à des vers la
publicité et examens on dirait qu'il
fait et vous arrêtez de m'engueuler je
vous engueuler quand ça souffle ses
petits arrangements avec nos consciences
qui font que on est là à revendiquer
parfois à la fin du patriarcat et quand
on envoie un pluie les patriat puce plus
il est en voilà un plus on va se dire ah
ben oui d'accord non mais pas lui non
non non stop